Centerville senior Primary Care the
sponsors of this segment are taking care
of patients and their caregivers we
can't forget about them and here's how
good to see you again Dr Wakefield great
to see you too Rocky now we're usually
talking about your patients at Central
well but this time we're talking about
their caregivers because it's just as
important to keep them informed as well
right
oh absolutely and where we really see
this as in emergencies right when it
comes to health especially emergencies
the best thing you can do is be prepared
emergencies happen in an instant and
time is of the essence So the faster you
act the better your chances are of a
positive outcome now what should our
loved ones know about being a caregiver
and what they should do in an emergency
well everyone but especially seniors
should have an emergency contact with
quick access to your health history
current health conditions medications
allergies preferred providers things of
that nature this will help guide any
emergency decision making that needs to
be done
and what kind of healthcare knowledge do
you suggest people have you know when
they are taking care of family or
friends
well even if you're not a Primary Care
Tech taker if you spend time with
someone 65 or older especially
one-on-one it's important to know
everything I just mentioned as well as
basic life-saving skills such as CPR and
even the Heimlich maneuver now do you
have any advice for caregivers out there
who you know who have a senior at home
I would recommend caregivers also don't
forget to take care of themselves
because you can't take care of others if
you're not up to you know your best so
really make sure to take time out for
yourself and you know do restorative
practices so that you're in you're
really the best shape to be a caregiver
for anybody else now what should our
viewers know if they do have a senior at
home that has an emergency what should
they do first
well if your senior loved one is
suddenly hospitalized with a
life-threatening condition you should
know the location of important legal
documents insurance policies wills and
trust and in the event that they do pass
you'll need to know their end of life
wishes
well that is always a hard reminder but
a really good one to have thank you so
much Dr Wakefield anything else you want
us to know it's my pleasure to be here
really
um if your viewers have any questions or
want to learn more I recommend them
visit
centerwelllasvegas.com or call the
number on your screen to request a tour
of one of the nearest Center well senior
Primary Care Centers our care teams are
here to help answer any of your health
related questions
thank you Center well senior primary
care for sponsoring this segment they
have 11 locations across the valley for
more all you got to do is head to
centerwelllasvegas.com we'll be right
back